[Music]
mom this is Kara it okay if she stays
for dinner do you need to check with
your mom my mom passed away recently I'm
so sorry honey
late nights tonight all night I'll let
you get to okay good night summer I am
so sorry that's okay mom do you want to
study again tonight sir maybe I get off
the work at 8:00 so I will text you you
know I'm Kara yeah what are you doing
here oh I got her study times mixed up
and I got talking to your mom
so what's the plan for tonight nothing
I'm grounded
what are you doing here
I thought we could study I said tomorrow
Oh Cara hey summer and I were cherry
just stopped by to see how I was doing
I can leave the cup when I was back at
Jefferson there's this guy thought do
you transferred from Hamilton that's
right I lived in Hamilton
then Jefferson sounds like you get
around this is Courtney one and your
mother were killed last year by a girl
named Ashley Carter this is the same
exact necklace that Cara wear to school
her first day you never appreciated
oh lucky you worked at a long she
deserved a better daughter and now
where's summer and why I'm here mom stop
calling me that I would have been the
perfect
you